hello and welcome to our real thoughts
and what I'm sure you wanna know are
real font size to see you dis mom
comment if we do soo much here gonna be
nothing but I spawned but that's what
the movie was anyway that's artists
my guess is actually this is gonna be a
short video because talk about really is
there's some stuff to talk about um this
is a bad movie everyone thinks this is
like the worst like whenever people ask
what's the worst movie you've ever seen
there is a Batman Robin to Batman Robin
oh no it's too funny for that yeah I
don't even know if I put it in like the
top 5 honestly it's one of those films
where it's like top 15 maybe it's so
it's so pathetic it's hard to put it up
I'm crazy sometimes that there is just
sort of a you just throw your hands up
in the air man what the fuck am i
watching kind of quality to it that it
sometimes at least it's kind of
interesting like it's like watching a
train wreck you can't quite look away
like it's a fascinating if this is what
this really is one of the few times
where it's a with every movie it's like
okay they weren't keeping track or
didn't keep an eye or something like
that but this is one of those where it's
like apart from visually because
visually it looks very nice you say it's
not I'd argue it's not Batman but it
looks very nice uh you know how could
anyone read this dialogue and look at
these lines whatever and be like how
could you not see um and this is like me
up uncle Alf well I mean and this is one
of those where it's like the only thing
I can gather but I think people just are
come to conclusion about is that they
just want to make a big screen
big-budget version of the Adam West Show
way but the reason the Adam West show
works is because it's not big screen and
not big-budget even they vote unquote
Batman movie they did with Adam West was
not big-budget ya know and it's it's
fascinating because it's like it's one
thing if you know you want to make it
like Batman Forever you know that made
more money than Batman Returns it was
definitely lighter
and you know hey let's just entertain
whatever and I think you know when we
saw like when we saw Batman the the Tim
Burton Batman and then Batman the
Animated Series come out like we grew up
with the atom was one two so we just the
superhero bright colorful whatever uh
but then it's like the comics the Tim
Burton movie in the animated series
we're like okay this is like this is
what Batman is like this is dark this is
gritty this is tough but it's really
creative and it's really weird and out
there it's wonderful um so I get the
feeling like when they did Batman were
up forever they're like okay make a lot
more like hard cos Batman Returns got a
lot of parents angry did pull in quite
the box office we wanted this is a
fetish movie and how awesome oh you
don't know no I think like Batman
Returns up to Batman and Robin they're
all fetish movies that was the funny
thing is they were all fetish movies is
just the other one appealed to the kids
more so it's okay cuz we dumbed it down
though you could argue like maybe the
first Batman has like the clown fetish
or what it is it is that fetish or fear
maybe both or I think about it but if I
didn't get to my foundation area what
chef bearish your Tisch umm but yeah so
it's it's bizarre that they I think
because they saw with Batman Forever
okay well we're trying to do kinda
heaven have kind of a seriousness cuz
he's dealing with the loss of his
parents and stuff and we still got heavy
shadows but obviously the goofy news we
had Jim Carrey and Tommy Lee Jones
basically acting like Adam West's
villains uh and but they also had the
Robin stuff the cow said so but when
they saw that did better they're like
okay obviously we want the bright and
colorful and more to the little kids so
let's make that kind of movie um that's
the only logic I can put in my head cuz
they're but I think maybe because they
weren't with but it didn't even feel
like a movie it just felt like sell toys
yeah no I know it's like it literally
just felt like here's some toy ideas
right a movie around this ya know it's
all I can think of it was very much a DS
cartoon it's actually cuz that's what
it's like an 80s cartoon that is bright
weird magentas Purple's blues and Greek
I know I think Schumacher was even
saying that like he was saying that the
toy companies would come up and say here
some of the toys we're putting together
work this into the movie here's a new
suit we're working for toy work that
into the movie and make sure you have
the nipples in the right um so it's it's
one of those things where it's like it's
on the one hand you just go how could
they not see it but I can't breathe I
say to myself it could be very possible
made they just like their thing the Adam
West one and the people that were making
this movie we're obviously a lot older
and they weren't seeing you know the
comics and the animated series and the
Burton one they just knew was dark and
the last Burton one that start didn't
make money so people don't want to see
that so let's make something bright and
colorful and just went full force um I
will say I will say this there is an
interesting irony in both incarnations
the Burton one and the Schumacher one
which is this the studio's took a risk
on both these guys and the first round
each time it paid off
Batman made off Batman Forever paid off
when they then wrote the blank check and
said here now it's your show do whatever
you want that's when it blew up in their
face because I will argue to this day
and this is partially why I do like
Batman Returns so much Batman to me is
not a pure Tim Burton movie it never
does it's very studio controlled it's
very the Batman Returns though is the
more pure timber I'm like okay love it
or hate it that is pure Tim Burton what
the fuck slathered all over the screen
and it's the same thing with Batman
Forever and Batman around but it's like
you know Batman forever more controlled
and then do this and I know Tim Burton
was producing but you know he's a huh
whatever I got Nightmare Before
Christmas yeah he's admitted that about
production too like he produced cabin
boy remember that Oh leo is just like oh
I didn't care about suing Nightmare
Before course Elias came up to me and
asked for a check and I wrote
yeah so so it was a studio thing and
then you know the studio was like yeah
make sure we get our McDonald's
promotion this Annette and then then
make it it can be dark but not too dark
and then Schumacher doses but then it
was a success so write a blank check
make sure you incorporate all the toys
have fun Joel and then it blew up in
their face again and it's reviled now is
the one the worst comic book movies of
all time killed comic book movies for a
while which is stuff I mean they were
seen as vid Scolari's to think of this
now but after that movie came out and
there was like that good like two or
three year gap later resurrected but I
mean it was just like wow we're done
we're never gonna move E's ago and when
when you did see him they were awful
they were really bad cuz nobody put any
effort it nobody put in the effort they
just the well be like BAM and then Robin
if we can sell some toys off this and we
also got into the I know we talked about
whatever the Man of Steel and no one's
stuff but I mean they were overly dark
they were trying to be really dull cuz
nobody took comic book seriously after
Batman Robin you know they're all seeing
his kids stuff so then all the comics
and all the movies are trying to be
really gritty and really dark but there
was no effort put into nobody threw a
lot of money at it or kept big watch out
or understood it so it was just it
really nonsense and it was directionless
blade helped and then you got a bunch of
blade clones where was all this limited
on my deck and they got x-men help too
and the Spider Man was the big holy shit
well and let's be honest here the matrix
between blade in the matrix I think that
signaled okay if you throw enough
special effects and okay but it wasn't
stylist that wasn't a comic book but
then with x-men and spider-man you
writing it kicked balls my play
especially x-men again was kind of on
blade level where it's like okay maybe I
said me as spider-man was like an
explosion said okay let's make more of
these now I like let's really really
throw our money into this yeah this this
movie killed it for a while you know it
really did and it's um and I'm trying to
think cuz it's it's not a fantasy here's
my problem with it I know some people
just like it's clearly not try yes close
I'm trying to eat Batman its but it's so
funny it's meant to be a comedy and it's
like I that's part of my problem
I don't find it that funny yeah
not that fun no much money on the screen
and it's so expensive that's the one
just where it is we have Michael Gough
we have Pat Hingle we I mean it's like
these are the actors from the first yes
in burn bad mood and I miss is supposed
to be cannon I mean how do we have
George Clooney we have uma Thurman could
act even back then we knew that like we
we have George Clooney who was a major
actor even back then you know crystal
Donald is some pretty boy but you know
is it are you define these are not
lightweights
yeah like so there is nothing in it made
us the only one that you would look at
and be like really okay maybe this will
be funny is Arnold Schwarzenegger who is
the most entertaining part of the movie
lion he is the only one that
legitimately Uma Thurman's early stuff
with clamp from gremlins to the side
he's great too yeah that character
actors amazing ah you'll have to talk
well I don't like your tone noise I
don't take rejection well I'm afraid I
don't like it scream and then and he's
so mad scientist II he's like Joseph
Gordon loved it and I freakin a GI Joe
was he's so ridiculous yeah um so that
early stuff was good but after a win uma
Thurman become sexy I'm just like okay
she's hot to look at that's it like you
it's just there's nothing funny about
her really it's just a Jessica Rabbit
voice like yeah that's it come on save
me some time so besides ed
Schwarzenegger is the only one that
legitimately makes me laugh like and and
he's just great he's doing his own thing
he's just like I mean a bad man feel I'm
going to have fun it just looks like
he's having so much pain he looks like a
little kid that got thrown in like this
gigantic ostrich an egg your suit is
like a we like he's jazzy he knew the
time of his lie is the 80 ton gorilla in
the room it's just like there's this
fucking gorilla in the room and you
don't know what the fuck its gonna do
but if you just stay against the wall
and watch you make it a few good laughs
out of it and that's what he does he's
just God he's great he is I mean that's
what I think people are like how can you
say they're they're great or any good I
think it's that even from a bad point of
view or just a lame comedy standpoint
they're just so strange and so so
we but so into it and there's there so I
know technique I think that maybe too
just because he's Austrian and even
though he'd been in the states revered
there's almost this foreign aspect to it
like maybe he's not aware of how he
should act in the absence of direction
maybe from Schumacher but he's so on a
different kind of almost crazy foreigner
level of acting in that film courses cuz
the other people are almost there trying
to take it seriously
except for maybe uma Thurman but
everybody else is acting straight and
Schwartz's like it's C in my opinion I
think like C I think half the actors in
Batman Forever thought they were making
a real legit Batman movie you know like
you know yeah Chris O'Donnell and
padding all and stuff like that uh but I
think the other half Nicole Kidman knew
she was in a goofy yeah no nope I think
the other hand of seungyun the other
have thought they were doing the Adam
West show Tommy Lee Jones had to know
that Oh Tommy Lee Jones is eating he's
the Arnold Schwarzenegger that film
because he's just fucking nuts no we're
with Batman and Robin with the exception
maybe Chris O'Donnell you know all the
other actors are like we're just doing
the Adam West bit where everything's
just gonna be over the table II you look
at Earl that's a very PC no Batwoman
there bad person that purse out of that
I mean it's like it you know that you
know George Clooney is like I'm just
gonna be Adam West you know it shorts
nigger is I'm gonna be one of the KCI
denim villains yeah I'm gonna be one
thing crazy you know it must have been
tough for him because that mask is tight
so yeah so the whole thing cut it must
have been it must have like created
ringing in his ears as he kept banging
against the sides of magic boy oh no no
it looks like he has some sort of
medical prom cause he's trying to swing
his head but the whole thing boo so he
just sort of looks like this I freeze
Batman
so those bobble heads um but that's part
of my problem is it I don't know what do
you think my issue with it is you throw
that much money on the big screen with a
pedigree of Batman coming off of I mean
even Batman Forever wasn't that silly
it's pretty silly silly
man Sanders but not to this level yeah
so to come off of the two dark films
Batman Forever and Batman the Animated
Series still running at this time Batman
Beyond would come up after this or
concurrent with this I know but and then
you get this and so many millions of
dollars spent on this I just don't think
it's funny like you threw that much
money and stuff into it it's not funny
it's just dumb yeah it's one of those we
just look it's like but again you could
say the same thing about the Adam West
Batman I really think that's what
they're looking at they're looking at
well this show ran for a long time they
even did a movie it was a success and
hey Batman forever they were a little
they were lighter and that got us more
money we got Jim Carrey as one of the
villains a big goofball but Adam West's
Batman it you can argue it's contrived
there are some people could argue it's
dumb they don't find it funny but you
weren't blowing the you know GDP of all
of Scandinavia on it like I just that's
one of those cases where I'm just like
couldn't have money been put to better
use but I think at least the Adam West
show if you don't like it I mean we do
was a cheap knockoff well no that's why
I think they're also obviously going for
kids because you know McDonald's and the
toy companies whatever we're like going
full force it is where I could end that
forever like Schumacher was saying like
nobody wanted to make that movie you
know they got it me but he's like nobody
was getting behind it cuz they were
afraid that Batman Returns and then
after forever was a hit everyone got on
board with Batman and Robin well and you
know it really do this today
horrible let's say you look at the
charge I mean that really is kind of it
and it's for a cheap knock like the
original Batman show was a cheap
knockoff but it was also free you can
just watch it on television well and it
was funny yeah roll down $10 and see
millions of dollars blown on something
like Batman and Robin maybe that's just
what I just don't find it that funny
it's too contrived too expensive and I
think it's the only reason I think
Schwarzenegger is the best thing in is
because there's almost a spontaneity to
him everybody else is reading off the
script I'm sure Schwartz Agurs reading
the script too but everybody else seems
bottled up where Schwarzenegger just
seems off the wall who do we want
ah your Hardee's would beat no more I
think what is he doing it's so much fun
so he's he's about the only thing but
yeah I know some people who get it that
I I get that some people find it like oh
no it's really funny like envy view it
as a movie made for kids yeah I just
think we treat our I wouldn't subject my
kids to that if I had kids I would like
one of the reasons I don't have kids
actually is because I don't want them to
ever be exposed to Batman and Robin like
something out of 7 I don't want to bring
them into a world where Batman and rap
mix very smart very um I should point
out by the way because everybody's like
do you think Joe Schumacher is the
biggest asshole and stuff like that with
all these directors all these writers I
mean all this stuff I've never got you
guys how can you go no but on topic most
my film if apologize I mean I've never
met these people you haven't either they
could be very nice people every time I
see him on an interview he seems like
the nicest guy he seemed like a very
genuine nice guy and he seems way nicer
than other celebrities amazed ya know
and he also yeah he came out and very
genuinely like harf al said look this is
what I was trying to do if you did not
enjoy them that's not what you're
looking for and you felt I did a real
disservice to Batman and I apologize it
was like that was very nice honestly I
don't mean I do I hate the film but it's
like eight it feels where when a
director apologizes for making art you
know it's like it's I mean I get the
Canon thing I get this means a lot to us
and then we we follow it but it's still
also just a movie seriously I'm very
happy and fun by active or emailed and
said I hate all comic book fans I hate
Batman ya know that really yeah then I
would demand an apology
I'm like wow you're douche bag you know
that's that's why when David Goyer
apologized I'm like damn straight you
should apologize dick yeah but I'm you
know I was trying to do what he thinks
is service to Batman and it clearly
someone it didn't understand what was
required and it's like you know and it
fucked up but it's like fair enough and
I feel weird when someone is doing
something out of you know
tried out of a good place and try and do
a service and it doesn't work and he
only when it's an all said and done
who's really to blame it the the fool of
the fool who follows the fool who wrote
him the check that's the issue I mean
you could look at Batman Forever
more so than even something like the
first Batman I think and get an idea of
where he would want to take it and you
the studio's wrote him the check said
here we want to sell a bunch of toys we
got deals left and right all the toy
makers around board yeah do this handed
it to this guy you're gonna blame the
guy now because he did what you wanted
him to do hmm
you know yeah I mean it's one of those
things where it's like I a lot of these
people it's like and even some of the
people like we look up to it celebrities
for all we know they could be dicks like
way we know I'll be honest the vast
majority of Joel Schumacher films don't
appeal to me yeah I don't but he said
but he's had a couple I loved falling
down that movie's stimming you know
everybody has their one or a handful
that still works uh I don't personally
hate Joel Schumacher I did for a while I
think in the same way a lot of people
hated George Lucas immediately after
Phantom Menace but then you know I was
also yeah 198 I was nineteen yeah you
bro I had that teenage angst and then
you know I spent a couple years in
college and you grow up and you're just
like oh like I know more important
things going on yeah um so it's like yet
anyone that's like do you hate that son
of a bitch yeah it's like don't do that
you've never met these people they can
be very nice people they could be dicks
too if they're I actively trying to
insult you as a movie goer and don't
give me that he did he made that man
around him no I'm afraid he is out there
behind the scenes in interviews saying I
hate all comic book fans I you know I
think Batman sucks I think if you like
Batman metal yeah then and there
writers and people out there have done
that and those are the people I don't
like but Joel Schumacher no I tease yes
he may have nearly destroyed comic book
movies as we know it but you know what
we're fine now and maybe if he didn't do
that we wouldn't be where we are now
with a thousand and one
Marvel movies and DC desperately trying
to catch up you know it it is what it is
yeah so comic book movie survived
they're doing just fine some people
would argue there's way too many of them
in that so obviously he didn't kill it
and therefore I don't hate him and the
one thing I do wanna bring up because I
always feel bad for not this is the one
thing I feel really badly now the review
another review was back in the YouTube
days I'm not even sure if it's ten
minutes you know it's very short um but
but the but but the one thing I really
wish I brought up is that I really wish
I said how impressive the sets are
because even though they're silly
they're still impressive and some do
yeah in agile a very tight yeah it's
actually a very technically impressive
film like I could see it like I could
see this world in another movie not
Batman but like in another movie and it
could be like really cool to look at
it's very I don't know what word you and
you like it's not my thing
cuz it's to try and search you v asaurus
and you can't I can't garish it's very
good pinks and blues and Monday's light
shining but I can see that like I have
no crazy terry gilliam type world or
something like yeah I didn't know it is
I didn't like the color scheme I'm not a
it just it was very retina burning and
my version of Gotham is probably closer
to the animated series or or Nolan's or
Burton's it's it's not a bunch of Pink's
I felt like I was at the Copacabana or
something winters and his Gotham but but
it was a technical achieve its still
impressive but I do really feel bad when
I don't acknowledge I hate this actually
visually is very interesting but it was
as terrible and stupid as it is it's
like it is still very visually
interesting not Batman but visually
interesting and it did give us what
could possibly be the creepiest Alfred
moment ever even trumping Michael
Caine's you know freaking war criminal
alfrid we burned down divorced Ida burn
it all down that's what he's is like I
took the liberty of making the
measurements myself and I'm like whoa
I'm like when when did you oh my god did
he chloroform her was she asleep and he
just sneaks in and like here with the
measuring tape like ooh like I was just
like oh my god
dirty old man it's like turns out I'm
not really your uncle he's like that's
why I don't have a British accent fill
me up
uncle F when I that move like I couldn't
take Alicia Silverstone like even
remotely seriously from yeah I couldn't
even laugh at her like is like well I
did she though that I never hated and
then that movie came out though and I'm
like oh hi honey I'm not gonna be able
to watch you in a movies a long time cuz
I'm just gonna keep seeing you suit me
up uncle outfit see you it Scooby Doo -
so yeah driving much what I had nothing
much else I guess I know everyone wants
me to the bad credit garbage just tell
at you that was the moment I've ever
seen on the big screen that was like
thee and um maybe we'll have like a
search for spy figure son but Batman as
of now he's officially dead like you
just killed that well there there seemed
to me you weren't paying attention when
you saw because he liked you like Batman
Forever better than Batman Returns know
what I was a kid I liked a man you
almost liked it better than Tim Burton's
baman which is sacrilege for you to say
now like no idea like would be open I
was a Jim Carrey a holic I was obsessed
with Jenny worry everything he did I was
like you know Jane is like donkeys not
many nights talking out of his ass he
still does um now you just have that
image in your head like yeah I think I
gotta stab myself in the eyes what were
we talking about I care now just think
about be talking out my ass which is
what I usually do anyway but still um
okay the bad man forever like I really
though Oh too bad credit card you so
flipped out over that and you were not
paying attention in Batman Forever cuz
for me that was the moment when I said
Batman's
and when I'm just like this film is
never going to recover because early on
in that movie he's on the fucking cover
of Time magazine and I'm like the credit
card bothers you the credit card it
could be a joke that only Bruce Wayne
has in his Batman costume or whatever
but time The Bachelor explanation of it
you never know it might be the Batpod
whatever he's a billionaire you can do
what he wants but he showed up too alike
and but Betty yes look at that but that
meet yeah and he shows up to a public
event but still to me the Time magazine
thing is the worst cuz that means he had
to at some point they said we're gonna
do an article on Batman do you think you
can show up yet get my bad side he shows
up stands there somebody takes a picture
of him and he's on the cover and was
like ooh
mystery man great disguise like you're
on a cover of a magazine I get that my
dad that's what ruined it for me and I'm
just like bed was my maroc no does not
compute this not compute uh you could
argue that me they just took the
pictures while he was running around
fighting crime but it is kind of how he
would die like the pause frame was he
holding some crew movies like no no good
think he's just really full and so I
will stop you here what does it okay I'm
just off you may be like Oh Batman just
hey yeah it's as bad as one picture like
there's a seam in the coal Kim it is
like a ton of pictures and like these
are photo shoot quaddle' all these words
only works if you're Lego Batman only
Lego Batman would be that egotistical to
do that so that I get you didn't like
the bad credit car but I just remember
you were so upset over that when we were
watching it together for the NC I'm like
I don't like this upset you who's on the
cover of Time magazine a Batman Forever
that's even weirder if you ask me so um
tell that stats about that's about all
we gotta say about it um still stupid
still dumb
um I mean doesn't maybe cuz the Nolan
Batman's would come out and Batman still
lives ie the character is just so good
it's not like quite the hearts time time
heals all wounds yeah so um yeah that's
about it and we will see you at the next
one take care good time yeah